serious allegations of past safety
practices and the workplace culture at
blue origin that's the space company
founded by billionaire jeff bezos blue
origin has had 17 consecutive successful
launches all of them cleared by the faa
however in her only tv interview former
blue origin employee alexandra abrams
tells lori siegel of 60 minutes plus she
believes the company sacrificed safety
because bezos wanted to win the space
race abrams is the co-author of a new
essay along with 20 other current and
former blue origin employees and this is
an interview you will only see on cbs
mornings
when i first joined blue origin i felt
like i was in star trek
and i think i came to tears once when i
was saying how grateful i was to be a
part of this journey
from 2017 until 2019 alexandra abrams
worked in communications for blue origin
a private space company owned and
largely funded by amazon owner and one
of the richest men in the world jeff
bezos the culture was
one of collaboration
innovation
excitement enthusiasm
nerdiness which i just loved
but that did not
stay the same for very long
blue origin's plan is wildly ambitious
to enable a future where millions of
people live and work in space to benefit
earth
but abrams who signed a non-disclosure
and non-disparagement agreement when she
left blue origin in 2019 says the
company's public message is at odds with
the reality she saw inside
i've gotten far enough away from it that
i'm
not afraid enough to let them silence me
anymore
in the last few years blue origin has
joined a modern-day space race alongside
bezos's fellow billionaires elon musk
and richard branson
blue origin reached a milestone this
summer when it launched its first manned
space flight with owner jeff bezos on
board abram says she saw women demeaned
at the company but her frustration
boiled over when senior leadership asked
her to help roll out stricter agreements
that she says took away employees rights
to resolve most disputes in court or to
speak freely about alleged harassment or
discrimination
i spend my days telling employees how
we're saving humanity in the planet
and on the other end i'm having the wool
pulled over my eyes about
taking rights away from our employees it
was not only
the hypocrisy that bothered me
it was the fact that i was propagating
the hypocrisy
i was actively participating abram says
she pushed back
she was fired in 2019. i was very
shocked like totally shocked
maybe i shouldn't have been
and i looked at
my new manager and said
you know i'm really curious like
what's the reason you're firing me
and he said
bob and i can't trust you anymore
she's referring to bob smith the ceo of
blue origin
since she left abram says she got
together with several current and former
blue origin employees often at her house
using a burner laptop so they couldn't
be tracked the plan
write an essay for the online platform
lioness.co criticizing blue origin for
its workplace culture and safety
practices
the people who signed on to this essay
are
absolutely incredible
brave
brilliant
human beings i look at this group
and i see
fighters for truth
fighters for safety
fighters for quality the essay accuses
blue origin of being rife with sexism it
says some women warned new female hires
to stay away from one executive who
appeared to be protected by his close
personal relationship with bezos it took
him physically groping a female
subordinate for him to finally be let go
women at blue origin were absolutely
treated differently than men
their ideas were not valued
as much they were not listened to
the essay says that in 2018 one team had
documented more than 1 000 problem
reports related to the engines that
power blue origins rockets which had
never been addressed 13 of the 21
signees are engineers
or technical they span all the major
programs of the company
and they also span
different levels we spoke privately to
five of abram's co-authors who are
staying anonymous because they fear
being blacklisted in a specialized
industry
several mentioned pressure to compete in
the private space race impacted safety
concerns it was great that blue origin
was smooth and steady
and slow
until jeff started becoming impatient
and elon and branson were getting ahead
and then we started to feel this
increasing pressure and impatience
that would definitely filter down from
leadership
do you believe that competing with the
other billionaires in the space race
took precedence over safety
yes
i do believe that cbs news has obtained
this 2020 internal memo written by a
blue origin engineer as he exited the
company it was addressed to company
leadership and reads our path is not a
sufficiently safe path would you trust a
blue origin vehicle going to space
unfortunately lori i would not
trust a blue origin vehicle going to
space
two former blue origin employees we
spoke with agreed with abrams and three
sources said staying on schedule often
trumped safety i mean it's an
extraordinary statement to be putting
out an essay with folks who are
engineers some who potentially could
still be at the company
saying
we don't believe in the safety of our
product
you cannot
create a culture of safety
and a culture of fear at the same time
they are incompatible
often times when i would try to
reconcile what i was hearing from the
engineers who are close to the vehicle
versus leadership about risk and safety
i would often go to leadership and say
okay how am i supposed to think about
this and often the response would be
oh well that person in particular just
doesn't have a high enough risk
tolerance that was said to you yes
blue origin's next space mission is
scheduled for week after next a launch
with four astronauts on board
abram says her essay was sent to the faa
before it was published online for folks
who are watching this who
see that and who say that the pushback
is blue origin said you were fired for
poor performance because leaders said
they couldn't trust you
they might say this is why you're out
there criticizing the company if that
was true then how would i have gotten 20
current and former employees to
contribute to this effort including very
senior people if i was known as a poor
performer
and someone who had bad decision-making
skills within blue origin would any of
these people trust me these are smart
people as the former head of internal
communications for blue origin what
message would you have for jeff bezos
today
i think i would say to jeff
that i really wished he was the person
we all thought he was
and that blue origin was the company we
all thought it was going to be
in a statement to cbs news blue origin
did not address safety allegations in
the essay but they said the company has
no tolerance for discrimination or
harassment of any kind and will promptly
investigate any new claims of misconduct
now blue origin told us abrams was fired
after repeated warnings for issues
regarding federal export control
regulations abrams told cbs news she
never received any warnings regarding
issues of that nature lori i think
what's striking about this is blue
origin is supposed to be blazing the
future for all of us and according to
these allegations they are stuck in the
past and running a risky culture but
abrams we have to underscore was fired
yep why do we trust her yeah and it
hasn't been with the company for two
years yeah two years right you know i i
think this is a woman who has a lot to
lose she's going up against a very
powerful company a very powerful man um
where she could face legal recourse um
and you know i think she was in charge
of employee communications
at the company and i think she believes
this is her way of being able to have a
voice for people who don't believe that
they can speak out now
you know why should we trust her i also
spoke to multiple other sources who had
similar stories all these different
sources shared stories that all sounded
like one another and i heard the same
themes over and over again i i think
about those four astronauts they're
going to be on a blue origin flight i
think a week from now
it makes me wonder what you heard from
people whose names we don't know about
potential technical problems with blue
origin you know look i think the one
thing i really took away was
besides a toxic or sexist work
environment and folks speaking out
against that was this drive to stay on
schedule impacted safety and this fear
that people had
that folks like engineers didn't feel
like they could go to the leaders and
say something because it might push back
um you know i think i heard that over
and over again and so breeding that
culture isn't a good thing when you have
these rocket ships going to space and
you have human lives but they also had
17 consecutive successful launches all
cleared by the faa and i'm very curious
about the safety question considering
jeff bezos himself was on the first
launch yeah it seems like if if there
was such a thing as being concerned
about he wouldn't put himself exactly he
wouldn't put himself in harm's way yeah
i think it's a good question right and i
think it's an important thing to note
there have been 17 successful launches
right this is a company um that is
buzzed about and for good reason um i
also think it's important um you know
the overwhelming message i got from sp
from folks where they were afraid to
speak out and they were they feared
retaliation for speaking out and in the
future this could have an impact is what
they said and that's why they wanted to
take the risk and do this all right lori
siegel thank you